Fully autonomous flight may seem easy.
You don’t need to stick to roads and have
much more space to maneuver and avoid obstacles,
but detecting other aircraft can be hard.
Even in the US 90% of low altitude flights
don’t require transponders that would allow
drones to detect other aircraft.
Drones need cheap and low weight sensors that
can see through fog and clouds with 360 degrees
of spherical sight.
Zipline had a batty idea to do this with cheap
off the shelf sensors.
Microphones.
Zipline has created a reliable system that
can pinpoint aircraft locations in 3D space
using these 8 microphones using signal processing
algorithms.
Allowing their drones to automatically detect
and avoid aircraft, bringing us one step closer
to safe drone integration in our airspace.